hello everyone recently the first
semester of first year got over here at
IIT kharagpur
and I'm sure the situation is the same
in almost all Institutes of India which
take admission through the je process
at this critical juncture when students
are truly completing their first step in
their transition from school life to
college life I thought that will be a
good idea if I can share some points to
emphasize and highlight certain very
important points which should which
students should keep in mind as they
make this transition so what are these
points the first thing which you must
realize after the completion of the
first semester is that
it is absolutely possible for a student
who has not had a very high entrance
examination rank to still be an
Institute topper at least get very good
results
so
it is not always true that the entrance
examination results directly converts to
the semester performance in fact in our
batch way back uh in that ancient
history of 2004 to 2009
what we saw was that a student who had
actually been admitted in their first
year in Ocean engineering and Naval
architecture which did not take students
with very high ranks so he actually
ended up being the Institute topper of
course he had done his Department change
at the end of his first year but that is
what it was so he doesn't directly
correlate the entrance examination
performance and the semester performance
the next thing you must realize which is
directly connected to the first point is
that if if you have been a very high
ranker in your entrance examination and
your results have not been very good
after the first semester actually you
must introspect where the fault lies
there is always a tendency or more most
often there is a tendency for the for
such kind of students to blame the
system to blame the sense system of
examination of this institute they are
of course Fanboys of the interest
examination in which they had performed
very well the jail process and they
blame that this The Institute the
semester of our examination system is
not at all very good and that is why
they ended up did not not performing
well the semester system is at fault but
perhaps introspect and realize that
maybe the fault lies with you maybe you
it is you who need to pull up your socks
and start performing well
stop being in denial that just because
your entrance examination rank was high
that will automatically convert to a
good performance in the semester
there are also some students these high
ranking students who think that okay let
me take a little bit break in the first
year and then I'll really start
performing to up to my potential from
the second year in certain cases it
happens but in most of the cases it
doesn't happen because once you lose the
momentum in the first year it's hard to
get back
please keep this in mind
on the other hand
if your performance in the first
semester has not been very good and
perhaps at the same time your interest
examination rank was also not very high
there is a tendency for the students to
completely lose confidence they start
thinking that perhaps they are not good
enough for the Institute perhaps they
are not good enough good enough for
engineering in the first place please
stop indulging in such kind of
negativity
first semester is only 1 8 of The
Journey in most of the cases for dual
degree students it's one tenth of the
journey there's a long long way to go
okay there is absolutely no reason for
you to start thinking that just because
the first semester results have not been
good everything is over actually we
heard some kind of extremely unfortunate
news
depending on the results
and I cannot emphasize this point over
and over again that please please do not
think that just because your first
Sinister exams have not been up to the
mark that you will not be able to buckle
up and perform better next time many
many students have done this before you
I'm sure you too can okay it does not
mean that you are not good enough it
only probably indicates that your style
of studying is not proper okay and as I
have already said it is very much
possible that despite a low rank in the
interest examination it is very much
possible for you to perform really
really well in the semester system and
realize that unlike the interest
examination the semester system is like
a marathon okay the entrance examination
is like a 100 meter sprint or something
like that okay to draw the analogy with
Athletics but the semester system is
like a marathon it's a cumulative
performance as it accumulates over and
over the semesters and over the years
okay so just because one semester is bad
doesn't mean that it is the end of the
road for you
okay so please take some hurt in it
another very important point is that
perhaps your semester performance the
first semester performance has not been
very bad but
it has not been so good that you are
going to end up with a department change
perhaps that was the hope with which you
came to the Institute perhaps you you
joined Some Dream Institute but you do
not get your dream department and you
had joined this institute with the sole
aim of or depending on the on the
possibility of the department change and
now after the first semester performance
you see that that dream is no longer
viable okay so maybe you are already
feeling a little bit stuck and you
somehow try to escape from the system
but you see no way out okay this is very
very common
and especially with the hype that is
going around nowadays regarding the
developments in artificial intelligence
and machine learning and all the
exciting buzzwords which you inevitably
must behaving
you may be thinking that just because
you have not been able to get into
computer science or information
technology or maths in Computing perhaps
you have completely missed the bus and
you are not going to be able to do
anything exciting in your actual
professional life this is completely
untrue please realize that every student
who is studying computer science now is
not going to be at the Forefront of
artificial intelligence technology he or
she is not going to be able to
contribute to at that level not
everybody is going to do that so there
is no guarantee that if you have been in
computer science you also would have
been there maybe you could have been but
it is no guarantee just because someone
is in computer science he would be part
of that exciting thing
plus it is extremely important to note
that on a on a longer scale let us talk
about the technology here you see it is
going to be only a very very few people
who are going to drive the actual
technological advancements associated
with artificial intelligence
what is going to happen
on a larger scale is that once this
technology is developed well enough it
is going to be applied in a variety of
real world scenarios real world
engineering applications
so the necessity the real necessity
would be for True domain experts to be
able to harness the power of such kind
of artificial intelligence within their
domains synergistically working with the
technology to find Creative Solutions to
seemingly unsolvable problems this
cannot be done by maintenance type of
low level Engineers for this real
scientists real Engineers with proper
genuine domain expertise is needed so
perhaps
if you think about it a little bit it
may be a blessing in disguise that you
are in your department which is not
computer science and perhaps it is an
opportunity for you to become given that
you already have some kind of an in
interest in artificial intelligence
become a true domain expert
maybe it will take four years five years
maybe it will take 10 years 10 but once
you become that true domain expert by
the time you are completely embedded in
the professional life in the future
you will get a very very good
opportunity to harness AI within your
domain as an application and please
understand this that such kind of true
domain expertise is what is going to set
you apart from the rest of the crowd so
my question to you now is this whether
at this point you will just sit around
complaining and regretting on the basis
of your first semester results or
whether you will buckle up and work your
way into becoming such a scientist or
engineer who becomes absolutely
indispensable to the professional world
for the next 50 years you decide thank
you very much and all the best